this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'm gonna talk about the quest to
dial down nitrogen today and I bet some
of you were wondering where I got that
title from somebody told me that they
were surprised to see the title from
someone serious like me so I'm not gonna
tell you who said that I'm gonna share
with you some information you can find
anything on the Internet there is an
advertising slogan generator there's the
URL now I had choices and it was hard
but I ultimately settled on this one
because I could relate it to my research
I liked this one but I couldn't think of
how to relate it to my research so if
any of you people to think of how to
relate this to what I'm talking about
today let me know afterwards okay all
right so today I'm going to talk about
some of the recent projects that we've
been working on in my lab and I want to
thank you all for coming and I really
appreciate this opportunity to share
this with you I'm going to first start
by talking about the context of the work
we do in the lab I am going to spend
about a third of the talk on that
because there are some new discoveries
that are really useful to apply to the
problems that we work on so I want to
spend time talking about that before I
go into three different projects which
I'll touch on briefly beginning with
some mass balance work and then I'll
talk about some of our work in nitrogen
fixation we've been doing quite a lot of
work on nitrogen fixation in many
different settings for the past few
years and then I'll tackle the monster
project that is the collaboration with
social scientists and biophysical
scientists about linkages across the
ecological social ecological interface
okay so the one thing that's notable
about the problem of nitrogen loss from
agriculture is its persistence and also
the global extent of the consequences of
this problem so about half the nitrogen
fertilizer is lost from agricultural
and this really varies depending on the
type of system that you're talking about
but it accounts for about three-quarters
of the anthropogenic nitrogen that's
been added to the global nitrogen cycle
and there's a number of environmental
consequences ranging from increased
greenhouse gas emissions and climate
change to changes in ecosystem species
composition function due to things like
nitrogen deposition and then also
eautiful or pollution of fresh water and
also nearshore marine environments so
that now we've got about 400 hypoxic
zones and actually the number is
increasing so before I go into some of
the work we're doing I want to just
review the nitrogen cycle really briefly
for those of you that don't live
immersed in nitrogen like we do so in an
unmanaged ecosystem the internal cycling
dominates most new n is coming in as
from nitrogen fixation and then there
are multiple loss it's feels weird to
use a laser being this close but I need
a stick there's a multiple lot I like
this better there's some multiple loss
pathways these are usually small but
they can vary and actually understanding
variation in these losses across
ecosystems has been a focus of a lot of
of forests and other ecologists working
on ecosystems ok we have a different
situation in agriculture we've got this
huge off take through harvest so to
compensate we add nitrogen fertilizer
which increases our inorganic nitrogen
pools especially nitrate which then
pushes these loss pathways particularly
denitrification and leaching in north
american to some extent ammonia
volatilization so how do we deal with
this problem
well what's notable about the approach
that we've used is that we're focusing
mainly on this single pathway here so
nitrogen fertilizer goes into the soil
in this plant available form and the
strategy is
to increase the efficiency or delivery
to the crop and there are many there's a
plethora of technologies that are all
geared towards increasing this
efficiency the sort of guiding sort of
the guiding strategy is the four R's you
can find this all over the internet with
you know how to improve your nitrogen
management focused on using the right
product at the right rate and time and
place so delivering it to the crop roots
when it's needed and this strategy has
been somewhat effective there are some
cases where the efficiency of fertilizer
use has been more than double by side
dressing for example five times during
the growing season is one thing that's
been effective so the approach that
we've used in my lab to address the
problem of nitrogen is is sort of
complimentary to this where we focused
on a number of processes at the same
time and there's two areas of ecological
research that are the basis for most of
our work the first comes from ecosystem
ecology and this is called the nitrogen
saturation Theory nitrogen saturation is
defined as when the nitrogen in flux in
exceeds the capacity of the ecosystem to
assimilate nitrogen through either plant
or microbial uptake or to store nitrogen
basically in soil organic matter
reservoirs for the most part in ways
that could be accessed by plants or
microbes later on so once you get beyond
this point then you are at saturation
and I'll talk about the symptoms in a
minute but this framework is able to
predict the ecosystem response in
pollution or atmospheric deposition and
actually that was one of the main
reasons why this framework was developed
by a group of ecologist working in
forested ecosystems in the northeastern
US so they were trying to explain
differences in nitrogen loss of
tension that they saw in these natural
ecosystems which were all in theory
undisturbed
they had very high biodiversity no
tillage you know why were they losing so
much nitrogen and this has had a huge
impact on ecology and I think also it
has potential to really inform
agriculture provides a framework for
understanding how nitrogen cycling is
connected to other elemental cycles in
particular this connection between
nitrogen and carbon is highlighted so
there we go so here's the symptoms of
nitrogen saturation can see beginning
from increased rates of nitrification
through to the losses and also the form
of nitrogen that's lost and increased
nitrous oxide fluxes from
denitrification these all are basically
what we see in agricultural systems
because we're managing them as a
nitrogen saturated system and this is
one of the challenges in trying to
reduce nitrogen losses by solely
focusing on nitrogen alone and so losses
are a symptom of nitrogen saturation
whether you're talking about forests in
this case these are 3/4 in you know in
North America compared to temperate
forests so a similar kind of environment
these are forests in South America
nitrogen deposition from human
activities it's very high in North
America and so we see very high losses
that consist mostly of nitrate in these
forests we see a similar thing in
agricultural systems with this
relationship between the nitrogen input
explaining about half the variation in
unrecovered nitrogen
so a second area of ecological knowledge
or research that is the basis for some
of our work is this is comes from
rhizosphere ecology and brian talked a
little bit about this a couple of weeks
ago at the grad review and the
recognition for the role of plant
microbial collaborations and driving
decomposition so one implication of this
is the realization that this very small
limited habitat the rhizosphere which is
my new compared to bulk soil in some
ecosystems actually dominates nutrient
cycling in some ecosystems because
there's so much activity another aspect
of this that's been it's had a big
impact it's just recognizing that here's
another adaptive strategy that plants
can use to for nutrient acquisition and
this that could be something that we
could intentionally manage in
agriculture so this is shaking this view
of decomposition as solely and
microbially regulated process sure you
can still put soil in a jar and you'll
still get decomposition and that is
useful for asking certain questions but
we have to realize that that's not
reflective at all of the decomposition
that could be occurring out in the field
or in a you know an intact ecosystem
instead of this collaboration between
plants and microbes where the plants are
providing labile carbon to the primary
decomposer so bacteria and Bunji
allowing them to break down the more
recalcitrant organic matter pools take
up nutrients the release of the
nutrients actually requires other
participants from the food web
so when grazers like protozoans feed on
these primary decomposers there's a net
loss of carbon and a release of
inorganic nitrogen and phosphorus that
can be taken up by plants and the
Predators also can play a role we've got
that
of complexity in here and your food web
and this all happens in the rhizosphere
very it's very tightly coupled this
process can increase decomposition
compared to bulk soil by two to tenfold
so that's some of the the numbers that
are out there and we think that this
mechanism actually that can explain this
observation that here's three of our
very important crops corn and small
grains and the majority of the nitrogen
that these crops take up comes from the
soil so less than 40 percent despite
having plenty of fertilizer less than 40
percent of the nitrogen in these crops
in 217 studies came from the fertilizer
so that's that's sort of the you know
shows us the challenge that we're up
against so if we take this information
together we can see that this problem of
leakiness in agriculture is is really
systemic and it begins with this use of
inorganic nitrogen which is the most
difficult form of nitrogen to actually
control in the environment and to keep
in ecosystem and it's exacerbated by the
fact that plants are going to take up
nitrogen from soil organic matter
because they've evolved along with
microorganisms to be able to access
those pools and then when this is
coupled with some of the structural
changes in rotations that have increased
fallows and have reduced inputs of
carbon into the soil or accelerated
decomposition through tillage we end up
with a soil that's got even less organic
matter so that we've got microbes that
are in the soil and they basically are
starved for carbon they're not
interested in nitrogen so the potential
to absorb nitrogen is is reduced in
these systems so there's kind of
multiple levels where we have this
problem of limited carbon and we end up
with loss pathways such as the United
to nitrate leaching predominating so we
use a typology to describe the different
strategies for approaching this problem
of nitrogen leakiness and from an
ecological perspective we can identify
three distinct strategies so one is end
of pipe where and we don't really work
on that very much so we just say well we
know that we're gonna lose nitrogen so
let's intercept it before it gets to the
places where we don't want it to be so
this is something that is getting a lot
of tension attention particularly in the
Mississippi River Basin where about 30
years of work at the field scale it's
still not resulted in significant
reductions in nitrate in the waterways
surrounding these lands okay a second is
fertilizer based or the single process
so I already talked about that one
that's the dominant approach and then a
third we call ecological or sea in
couple so these approaches manage
multiple processes and then are focused
on agro ecosystem scale nitrogen
retention as part of the process with
the strategy of reducing the nitrogen
surplus since we know the surplus from
nitrogen saturation theory we know that
the surplus is a big driver of losses so
one way to reduce losses is to be able
to somehow reduce the surplus nitrogen
that you're adding to the system
so I'm gonna start by talking about some
of our work with field sale nitrogen
mass balances and our question here is
basically how does management impact
field scale nutrient flows and of course
our hypothesis was that these methods
that involve increasing carbon nitrogen
coupling or that are targeting or
impacting multiple processes that affect
nitrogen retention are going to show
reduced surpluses and reduce nitrogen
losses and I'm going to talk about two
pieces of work from my former graduate
student Jennifer blush we first did a
meta-analysis of the m15 literature or
to ask this question what are we finding
in the experimental plots in terms of
nitrogen recovery and then we went to
the Mississippi River Basin to those
grain systems because a great deal of
this research that's been done on
nitrogen using in 15 has been done with
grain systems particularly in temperate
systems so these are some of the results
from the meta-analysis so for those of
you not used to looking at these so if
there's no effect of a management
practice and the management practices
are listed here so I'll take
nitrification inhibitor as an example
there's no effect then we'd see the
average change here at zero instead we
have it at nearly 7% so this means that
compared to the standard practice which
is broadcast fertilizer in most cases
using a nitrification inhibitor increase
the nitrogen fertilizer recovery by
nearly 7 percent ok so we can see we
kind of grant we've got them arranged in
order of the two practices that focus on
fertilizer proximity to the roots and
the timing particularly you know fall
versus spring had the greatest impact so
increasing the recovery by 24 and 18%
but compared to these we had to sort of
ecologically
based or cm coupling based practices
prop rotation so this is a more complex
crop rotation that reduces bear fallows
and then the source of nitrogen could be
manure compost or leggings most were
legumes and manure and both of these
practices increased recovery by about
thirty five percent so we wondered well
what will we see if we go out to
farmer's fields will we see this kind of
a range in the recovery or loss
reduction well you can't manage you
can't measure losses out in working
fields very well unless you've got you
know a sort of a multi-billion dollar
budget to put all the instruments out in
the field and a bunch of farmers who you
can then pay for all the inconvenience
of doing that so instead of trying to
measure losses we constructed budgets
for these fields simple nutrient and
nitrogen mass balanced budgets so first
of all we look for we found four regions
in the Mississippi River Basin where we
could actually find a diverse range of
farms and this is not easy to find in
that in that part of the country so we
were able to find systems that range
from the dominant corn soybean rotations
to those that some that incorporated
winter grains or had some diversity in
their rotations to others that include
perennials forages legumes and then some
we also found organic production systems
that don't use any fertilizer nitrogen
at all so that was our continuum in
these four regions we identified 110
feel farms and use two fields in in each
of those to construct a budget and it's
a simple input-output budget so the
inputs were fertilizer biological
nitrogen fixation and nitrogen from
manure and then the output output that
we measured was the nitrogen harvested
and we constructed the budget just as
exports subtracted from inputs to get
the balance and we know that surplus
will drive losses so the greater the
surplus all other things being equal
the more vulnerable the system is for
nitrogen loss if we find deficits then
there's a danger of mining soil and we
found that these mass balances agreed
very well with what we found in the
meta-analysis from the research plots so
the liking base if we look at the
nitrogen sources the legging base had
the smallest surplus meaning that they
have the least their least vulnerable to
nitrogen losses there was a an
interesting difference between spring
applied versus fall applied manure so
systems that put manure at different
times that they put on the fall they
tend to really be over applying nitrogen
and then the fertilizer based methods
sort of fell out in the middle here with
surpluses that range for about 35 to 38
kilograms per hectare per year and if we
look at rotations so this is just summer
annuals just corn soybeans this is we
had only 29 fields that actually
incorporated a winter annual only and
then we had almost 70 that had
perennials and usually perennials often
means that they also have leggings so we
cannot tease apart the effect of
rotation or perennials from the use of
biological nitrogen fixation that's one
of the the challenges of doing on-farm
studies but we say that you know we feel
good because this agrees with the
meta-analysis and also with the
predictions of nitrogen saturation
theory
oh gosh I'm sorry I was pointing out the
these are the surplus so this is the
input this is I'm yeah this is the
addition this is the export and that's
the surplus yeah that's right there's no
key there this is the danger of yeah
okay clear now yeah sorry
okay the other interesting relationship
that we see in this dataset is that as
you increase the proportion of nitrogen
that's derived from biological nitrogen
fixation you also reduce the surplus and
we do have some here that are showing a
small deficit we only saw this
relationship if the nitrogen rate the
annual additions were over where eighty
one kilograms per hectare or over but it
was pretty consistent we've also seen
this in some of the regional farms and
I'll I'll show you some of that so this
is an intriguing result because it
suggests that you know there is some
inherent efficiency a rule of increasing
the proportion of nitrogen fixation that
you're using in your system so we think
that these results show that there's
there's multiple benefits it's a win-win
situation not only do we reduce nitrogen
losses which is what you get if you
improve fertilizer use efficiency which
is a very important outcome but we also
will see reduction in greenhouse gas
emissions because nitrogen fixation is a
solar-powered technology and I think
it's one of the underused solar-powered
technologies that are out there so we've
got a great one in agriculture so we
also end up building organic matter
reserves which will enable plants to
rely on this mechanism that they've
developed over through evolution over
love breaking down organic matter and I
assessing those pools that is a very
tight tightly coupled system and it's
it's quite resistant to nitrogen losses
since it's occurring in the rises very
very small spatial scale and there are
other benefits such as some drought
resistance that can accrue as you build
organic matter pools okay how am i doing
I'm doing okay I'm gonna move on to talk
about nitrogen fixation and specifically
I'm going to focus on some of our
on-farm work that mega japan ski did
when she was here doing her doctoral
research and we start out with
originally when farmers were asking lots
of questions about nitrogen fixation how
much nitrogen they thought they would be
getting from these green manures
we went to the literature because I was
not doing research on nitrogen fixation
we found that there was just very little
information particularly on the kinds of
legumes that were being used as dream
manure crops there's a lot on soybeans
not too much in farmer's fields there a
fair amount on alfalfa but for many of
the species that farmers are using in in
the Northeast there was just very little
data so we started by looking at
nitrogen fixation in organic rain and
vegetable systems and also some
conventional systems so nitrogen
fixation really should be the primary
source of nitrogen for organic farming
because haber-bosch nitrogen is
forbidden when farms use composts from
conventional agriculture they're
actually you know subsidized through
synthetic nitrogen but it's you know
it's allowed because they are recycling
a waste but the reliance on nitrogen
fixation is even worse in organic
vegetable systems and there's a number
of reasons for this I'm not going to
talk about that now so we have this huge
range just in organic systems in terms
of how well they're managing and using
nitrogen fixation when we look at the
impact of this on the the balances we
see that it really doesn't matter
whether you're talking about haber-bosch
nitrogen or
pose if you're relying on those kind of
inputs and using very little nitrogen
fixation you tend to have larger
surpluses these are the organic grain
systems that have much higher proportion
of nitrogen coming from nitrogen
fixation
so these organic vegetable systems are
creating an environmental problem as
well even though they're using a
different source of nitrogen they are
operating they may there may be a delay
in the rate of nitrogen loss but
eventually those systems will become
saturated even though they're adding
some carbon and also they tend to have
really an over application of phosphorus
to in these cases so we were very
interested in looking at how differences
in soil fertility impact nitrogen
fixation we also wanted to understand
how planting the legume either as as a
monoculture or with interceded grasses
impacted nitrogen fixation we expected
that in fields and this was done in
regional farms in the Finger Lakes with
you know variations in their history of
management we expected those that have a
legacy of using legumes would have
higher soil organic nitrogen pools and
that there may be some suppression of
nitrogen fixation because if you have
more nitrogen available in the soil then
normally the leggings down regulate
nitrogen fixation because it is so
energy intensive
we also expected that when the in leaves
red clover in this particular experiment
that red clover planted with the wheat
interceded with the wheat may fix
nitrogen at a higher rate but it might
end up fixing less total nitrogen
because of reduced growth so maybe
competition from shading for example
could end up reducing the total
Thanks these are some of the things that
we we thought we would see so we in this
experiment one central piece was to look
at the frost seeding of red clover into
winter grains grains and evaluate the
performance of that practice because
this is a very important practice in
organic grain systems and it has many
benefits in terms of keeping the soil
covered and reducing tillage so in order
to do this for those of you who aren't
familiar you start with wheat in the
winter and the legumes the red clover is
frost seeded germinates in the spring
canopy closes and it stops growing for a
while until harvest takes place there's
a small campaign and then after harvest
when the grains removed it fills the
field you have a field of sand a red
clover that could be cut but it is used
as the green manure for nitrogen
fertility for the following corn crop so
these these this research was conducted
by embedding replicated plots into
farmer's fields and I'm I'm not gonna go
through all the methods here if you have
questions ask me later on so we did find
that as the proportion of reliance on
nitrogen fixation increased that overall
nitrogen fertility increase and this is
from a number of measurements that
beginning with the inorganic poles
through some of the labile pools to the
total organic nitrogen pool because one
single measurement really isn't a very
good indicator indicator of nitrogen
availability in the soil but we didn't
see even though we had a fair amount of
variation we didn't see any suppression
of nitrogen fixation in the clover that
corresponded with increases in soil
fertility we did see some significant
impacts of the way the clover was
planted with clover and a monoculture
having a lower fixation rate so in when
Curt clover was growing by itself
without a non legume as competition
it was able to take up more nitrogen
from the soil and fix less compared to
clover that has interceded with the
winter grain or clover planted with
orchard grass and this was our other
comparison this is the Parma practice
this was clover planted with a perennial
grass however when we looked at the
total nitrogen fixed we found that it
was actually highest in the farmer
practice because well the rate of
nitrogen fixation increased but there
was no reduction in total biomass
production of the clover
we're so close and a monoculture had a
great biomass but not as much nitrogen
from fixation clover with orchard grass
had a higher rate but a significant
suppression in the overall growth or
biomass production and that ended up
reducing the nitrogen fix so from the
perspective well the farmers are doing
the right the right thing in terms of
managing clover in these systems and
managing nitrogen fixation so we start
with brain farms because they're a lot
simpler to do this kind of work in they
have similar crops they're located on
some similar soils where is the organic
vegetable systems where we we have a lot
of problems and managing nitrogen
fixation and farmers have there's a lot
of interests on the part of farmers and
work that will serve inform their
management we were working up to them
but in the grain farms we found some
very variability in soil nitrogen
fertility but it's below the threshold
for nitrogen for BNF suppression and
this is not the case in vegetable
systems we know that fertility is high
enough that it is suppressing nitrogen
fixation in some of these farms a
strategy that uses interceding in a way
that minimizes competition between the
legumes and the non legumes is really an
optimal strategy you get the benefits of
competition for soil nitrogen and you
know reduce nitrogen availability to up
the fixation rate but since their growth
has staggered that gives the clover a
chance to grow without competition for
light and this on farm work and we have
some work we've done in vegetables
systems as the basis for the next phase
of research and cover crop mixtures that
Emily will be carrying out she talked a
little bit about that
ok I'm on the last project I'm actually
doing ok I mean I thought 3 might be
pushing it but I know two just seemed
you know three nice around ok so I'm
gonna talk a little bit about the
interdisciplinary project that used the
Mississippi River Basin and the problem
of hypoxia sort of a case study to try
to understand how the linkages across
the social ecological interface drive
agricultural management regimes land use
and intensification and you can imagine
here's the research team and their
institutions and various specialties
that this is a complex project and we
all complain those of us that do this
work that even we're always you know at
meetings giving talks in 15 or 20
minutes which is really hard for these
kinds of projects but I'm going to just
pick a couple of things to show as
examples to maybe pique your interests
and get you interested in doing this
kind of work it does take time but it's
been a really valuable experience I've
learned a lot from people from the you
know the cross disciplines so the
Mississippi River Basin epitomizes an
intensive industrial system that is high
yielding it is one of the most important
food production systems in the world the
last statistic I have which might be
have gone down a little bit as
production expands out into developing
countries was nearly 80% of the world's
feed grains come from the Mississippi
River Basin and there is an extensive
network of research and extension and
government policies that support this
agricultural system and there's also
some very significant
consequences
the main one being that you've probably
are familiar with is the dead zone or
the hypoxic zone in the Gulf of Mexico
and so far although there have been some
improvements and fertilizer use
efficiency in these systems so far it
hasn't impacted the nitrate levels in
streams draining the basement or the
hypoxic zone so this is this year's the
size of this year zone they tack it
every year it's smaller than predicted
and they've got some ideas about why
that is but it's right just barely above
the five year average so we're not
seeing a you know a trend downward yet
and there's some ideas about why there
might be some lags in this system so the
two overarching questions of this
project one of the key social ecological
linkages governing the current
agricultural systems and how could these
linkages be modified to expand the
ecosystem services delivered by this
this agricultural system I'm going to
talk specifically about some work that
was done in collaboration with Stephen
loaf and his graduate students Stephanie
- angle Ike Meyer and so one way that
this is framed is to look for evidence
of adaptive coupling which is defined as
an appropriate response to environmental
degradation so one question that was
addressed in the project our resource is
targeting the regions that are
responsible for the hypoxia and I'm
going to talk about research resources
and then the policy driven incentives so
first we need to look at well where are
the nitrogen loss that's coming from
they're ending up in the Gulf this is
work done with Mark David using County
level nitrogen budgets and when we run
that analysis we find that you know the
losses the greatest losses occurred here
in this blue zone and as color gets
lighter they get lower and lower and so
these losses are driven by the intensity
of the agriculture the
there was a proportion of the area
that's in corn fertilizer rates and the
presence of tile drainage and this turns
out to be a real key factor separating
out what tile drainage is it was
invented in New York anybody not know oh
there okay I'll tell you what it is then
basically it's installing these pipes
which used to be made out of tile now
they're made out of plastic about a
meter down in the soil the depth varies
depending on soil type and they have
holes their prints drain
so in these heavy soils which are you
know many are former wetland soils it
provides drainage so the water instead
of standing percolates down into these
drains and then moves out of the field
underground into a bunch of drainage
ditches that surround there's a network
so this has a huge impact on
productivity and this was really what
enabled some of these wetland soils
which are high in organic matter to
become hugely productive for these crops
okay so let's look at the resources in
terms of research so for this we
analyzed the USDA Chris database and we
analyzed ten years of data looking at
profit projects that related to nitrogen
management and Stephanie use that
typology that I mentioned earlier end of
pipe fertilizer and ecological and first
of all she looked at the amount going to
different regions so here's the Corn
Belt that's where the problem is
here's the Gulf of Mexico States they're
the recipients of the problem and a
greater amount of research on nitrogen
management is going to the problem area
recipients not the people making the
problem so it was interesting and this
was that was actually one of Stephen
Watts prediction so if we look at the
temporal trend in investment we see a
similar thing
this is for the Gulf states where
overall total investments going up in
the Corn Belt states where the overall
investment is going down so this is just
one database it's just the crisp
national database we would have really
liked to look at state budgets for
research but that's pretty much
impossible and that is one of the
problems that we found is that there are
many things that would help us to
understand how well we're doing in terms
of tackling this problem but the data is
simply not available and a lot of this
is data more in the social system
resource allocation for example okay so
the second sort of resource allocation
question has to do with the incentives
that are generated by our aggregate
aggregate environmental policies and so
this is the farm bill which is slated to
change if they ever passed another one
however the proposed insurance based
incentives will actually parallel the
commodity sort of yield subsidy based
incentives in terms of the farms that
qualify for them so what we found if you
can remember the dark areas contributing
to hypoxia is that the payments for crop
production naturally are going
predominantly to the areas that have the
high yields and are the most intensified
but they're also the areas that are
contributing to environmental
degradation if we look at conservation
payments we see just the opposite where
those areas that are really productive
and have the high corn yields and also
are the most leaky and contributing most
of the nitrogen to the streams are not
interested in conservation payments
which tend to be less so this is not
nearly as lucrative as the crop payments
now there's a lot of things going on
within the policy world and in NRCS to
try to correct this situation so this is
not people are aware that if you have a
high yielding farm you've got fertile
soils most of the conservation options
that are going to improve your nitrogen
management just are not economically
appealing to you and that's something
that can be addressed through policy so
we're in the midst of doing some work
with this database of this county level
database that has all the agricultural
practices fertilizer use and all of that
information by combining it with the
crop protic the soil productivity index
that's been developed by NRCS and data
from the census of Ag the economic
census and the what is it the new one
community American Community Survey yes
now we have a new beyond beyond the
census we have a new survey that
captures socio-economic data from
communities so we're in the midst of
taking the next step with this to try to
understand how the biophysical
environment impacts agricultural
structure and whether or not and ask
whether or not there are cascading
effects for rural communities and the
questions we're looking at here how does
the biophysical setting influence
agricultural intensification and the
response of agriculture to policy market
signals so we know about you know the
counties that are actually receiving
payments we know about their impact on
environment in the environment and the
structure of their agriculture we want
to ask is it going to the next level up
of the community the soil fertility
influence the socio economics of rural
communities in intensified landscapes
we actually didn't think there would be
very much of an impact given you know
the the high degree of industrialization
of the system and it's it's you know
reliance on technologies and inputs to
produce yield so I'm just gonna show you
a couple of plots of the data we will be
doing some multivariate analyses of this
data because that's really the only way
that you can analyze this sort of a
complex data set but the initial
correlations look promising so yes corn
yields are higher in the soils that have
the higher productivity potential index
so that made me feel good about the NRCS
index and we see that intensification so
this is a question about if we compare
the corn acreage in this period in the
1960s to corn acreage from 2002 to 2006
how how the change has been on a county
level basis so if they're down here in
the negative we lost corn acreage if
they're up here we gained corn acreage
so from this you can see that
intensification is continuing and it's
continuing in those counties that are
already the most intensively managed and
are also the problems from the problem
counties from an environmental impact
perspective so the policies are
continuing to foster and exacerbate the
environmental degradation that is
currently occurring and then if we look
at some of the relationships between
productivity and economic outcomes first
looking at the percent of farms
reporting losses we find an inverse
relationship so the proportion of farms
that report losses in high fertility
soils is much lower compared to those
that are in the lower fertility soils
and in this relationships was even
stronger than the relationship to corn
yield
suggesting that the policies that were
using the incentive
that reward yields actually exacerbate
differences that are occurring due to
the differences in soil fertility and
then this last one is looking at the
impact of soil fertility on the number
of families living below the poverty
level so the question is does this
difference in soil fertility and farm
structure and you know the intensity of
Agriculture the incentives that you know
are passed down from the agro
environmental policy does that impact
the broader community and and we see
that there is a correlation of our
square root of 0.29 with lower rates of
poverty related to the high fertility
soils I mean this is commonly seen in
subsistence agriculture but I was kind
of surprised to see I mean that's a
pretty strong relationship so the the
work that we're doing with this database
which were we're building we're adding
other variables in will be will be
looking at this relationship between
soil fertility access to to amenities so
shopping in grocery stores medical
facilities and those kinds of things
because the the syrup type has been that
people that live in counties well based
on stereotype 8 on some research in
California we expected that counties
with the highest productivity and the
greatest intensification would have
overall lower or reduced quality of life
based on the immunities available
because you have a depopulation of the
counties where you've got lots of
agriculture
I'm sorry yeah it's it's based on census
data so it's all families in the county
so it'll be people working in
agriculture and everybody else
well and I this is only rural counties
yes yeah and that's a you know this is
just the first course analysis we have
to look at a lot of per capita questions
right yeah because if you if you leave
the urban counties and it really
confuses things because urbanization
tends to occur where the more fertile
soils are so that you know really throws
a wrench in yeah so from now we've left
those out okay yeah so to summarize what
we what we found so far from this
project and it's I'm mostly limited it
to some of the the results that I
presented so looking at this as a system
it's evident that maladaptive coupling
dominates in other words the way the
system is responding to policies really
at a national level that that keep
pushing it on its current trajectory of
intensification and of you know
production or yield as the main focus
some counties have actually taken steps
to try to reverse that trend at the
county level because they realize that
they're they're losing their communities
and so there are incentives such as five
years of no taxes if you convert to
organic farming and certain counties
have implemented programs where they
preferentially buy produce from local
farms in order to provide a market
because if you're out in the Midwest you
really are tied to the global market for
the most part so if this is due in part
to these commodity payments that support
support mainly corn soybean production
and sort of leap over and you know swamp
or just completely you know overwhelm
any local initiatives for the most part
and this and this intensification is
particularly pronounced in the areas
that are you know really mainly
responsible for nitrogen loss and
in the Gulf of Mexico and if we look at
this research and policies there's sort
of a you know an irrational allocation
of resources at this point which needs
to be corrected ok here's my final slide
oh I made it in time so ok so how can we
reduce nitrogen well of course I think
that we need to exploit ecological
processes and this this will be a
challenge because there are many
barriers that exist in institutions and
you know if government policies I've you
know if you meet with economists they
like a single number they don't like a
complex sort of you know decision matrix
of a than B or if C then go to Z they
don't like any of that they don't like
interactions and but of course what
we're doing when we use these ecological
approaches is we're trying to take
advantage of these interactions that
actually drive the system in the
direction we want to go to have multiple
benefits so more than yield you know to
deal with water quality to increase soil
organic matter and the sort of cascade
of positive outcomes that are offered
there so I don't think that haber-bosch
nitrogen is going to go away I think
it's an important tool and we should be
strategic about how we use it because
you know while we still have cheap
fossil fuels and we can supplement with
solar based technologies that could be a
key strategy for transitioning
agriculture towards sustainability and
I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you
okay sorry I was disoriented for a
minute it sounded like you were coming
from above yes
therefore it seems like that
I would be
well you know there's a lot of people
talking about changing diet I mean 40
percent right now 40 percent of the corn
is going to ethanol so you know that is
an issue we export a huge amount for the
grain I mean for feed grain so it's a
really a global diet issue not you know
not just our own diets so I think that
you know there are some challenges but I
also believe that I think that we could
increase the diversity of our landscape
without taking a huge hit in yield one
strategy would be to substitute wheat as
one of the feed grains which is already
happening in organic systems for a
variety of reasons so this you know part
of the problem is this complete reliance
on corn soybean of course I am a strong
advocate of you know eating meat in
moderation recognizing that you know
it's ecological cost but I think that
that is a you know a much broader
challenging cultural question certainly
we should not be encouraging meat
production to be you know cheap I mean
we should try to incorporate the real
cost into different foods so rather than
have our government you know try to
subsidize the production of meat and
other animal products so that they are
inexpensive maybe you know some way to
balance and I think a lot of the work on
ecosystem services is looking at you
know how can we monetize and get some
actual you know cost that reflects the
true environmental costs or that the
things that we have externalized so that
is a very good question and it's more
than I can answer in two minutes
oh my god must have encouraged this
well I think that I do think that we
should continue to provide incentives or
subsidies for agriculture I think it's
different than other industries and I
think that we want to keep as many
people in farming as we can or as we
have right now I don't think people want
to continue to go down the road of you
know reducing the number of farmers even
more and and having farms you know
increase in size there's no evidence
suggesting that that's really going to
improve their ecological efficiency and
there's questions about the value in
terms of production outcomes a nitrogen
tax is is something that's been on the
table and I think that Europe the iou's
EU has gone that way and in certain
respects putting caps on nitrogen
fertilizer rates I actually think that
experimenting with a couple of those
kinds of tools to sort of help the
transition begin one might be rewarding
farmers for cover which is something
that NRCS is trying to do so they do
haven't small incentive program for
cover you know increasing your coverage
reducing their fallows I think that in
certain places no-till is reasonable and
combined with cover cropping it can be
valuable policies that would encourage
the integration of animal and crop
production so that they're not spatially
separated and distinct from one another
could have a lot of benefits that you
know the ultimately if the most
efficient rotation is one that includes
crops that relate to animal production
so pulling forages out of the grain
systems is one thing that's led to a lot
of the problems that we have in those
systems so that could be a key thing
applying fertilizer careful
so when you go to the legumes they have
problems with adjusting
okay
well you know first of all I don't think
that the responsibility can all fall on
farmers because the systems that they
have now that are dependent on the
technology that's been developed to
support this intensification actually
make it more difficult to the you know
backtrack and add diversity in so there
needs to be some you know work at the
higher level and there needs to be
research on how to go back to using
biodiversity in a way that makes sense
strategically and results in these
multiple benefits in terms of managing
legumes though one benefit because
you're impacting so many processes is
that you don't have to manage them as
closely because you do you build up the
labile organic matter pools so we just
did a pilot experiment with a you know
soil from a conventional field soil from
an organic field 20 years-plus of
organic management and about the the
wheat took up about twice as much
nitrogen from the organic soil and was
able to produce you know a yield that
was twice as high as the wheat from the
conventional so even though we added
some you know small amount of legumes
residue so initially it's more of a
challenge but you can always supplement
legumes with fertilizer you don't you
know how different less you're aiming
for organic certification so the farmer
was interested in legumes I would tell
them I mean I would give them
recommendations about the legging to fit
into their niche you know the open spot
they've gotten their rotation and then
maybe talk to them about how to eyeball
it and be prepared to add some
fertilizer to get them through
right I think once that you've been
managing your soils in our climate
organically for at least ten years that
if you have a low stand of clover you're
you you could potentially get away with
it I mean you might want to supplement
but I mean there's still not a lot of
data on that and you know what how to
sell type interact with management in
terms of rebuilding these labile pools
but it's definitely some of these more
labile pools that are available to
plants that are being impacted which is
what we want to do now one question is
since these plant these soils do have
greater capacity to mineralize nitrogen
you know are they going to be more prone
to leakiness our cover crops enough to
capture that nitrogen so we really have
to be we really have to avoid bear fouls
if we're going to build up these organic
matter pools we could have other
problems
okay thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu